As if he had forgotten what he had laughed at, he taught me politely every day Even if
I teased him or pranked him, he didn't look like he was speeding up the key
In the
first place, Hara, you trust no one in the land and the road, and the truth is that you were in favor of Gray.
Oma and
Kanidasu, I've been strange since I started coming here.It's
not that I don't like that teacher, just because I feel
calmer with Doll.  It's not that kind of person
Well, I guess you can still think that he picked a
rose What is that person
thinking?  My
chest feels tight and my face gets hot Sometimes
I want to tie Guren-sensei So
, in 5
[Music]
What are you talking about?
A man has also
fallen asleep,
hasn't he
?  I think
I'll write down your troubles when I wash them I've already experienced
them
I'll tell you The name of the disease you're suffering from is Dr. Glenn's love
[music]